إذا فكرنا في السنتين اللتين قضينا فيهما الوباء
الآن ، فإن
الأمور تبدو أفضل بكثير ،
فقد استغرق الأمر عامين
لأننا
أولاً وقبل كل شيء كان علينا أن نبدأ
بتلقيح أكثر من 92
بالمائة من سكان الإمارات العربية المتحدة.  نتحدث عن 22
مليون شخص
نتحدث عن الشركة التي تم
تطعيمها أيضًا بأكثر من 90 في المائة
من إجمالي موظفي الشركة ،
وعلينا أيضًا أن نعتقد أنه يتعين علينا
الاعتناء
بأنفسنا وكذلك الأشخاص من حولنا
وعائلتنا  علينا أن نتبع القواعد
كرئيس للرجل المسؤول كيف ترى أن
الإمارات في
مرحلة ما بعد
الوباء تختلف عن شركة الطيران
قبل الوباء من
الناحية الاستراتيجية ، كيف تراها بشكل
مختلف ، فنحن نأخذها دائمًا إذا
فعلنا ذلك قبل الوباء  ما هو
سبب عدم قدرتنا على القيام بذلك بعد
الوباء ،
علينا أن نتحلى بالسرعة ،
فلماذا لا تقوم فقط بدمج الإمارات
واتحاد الآن يقول كل من الرئيسين التنفيذيين توني دوغلاس والسير
تيم إنهما أعلى من
راتبهما ولكن  t هي درجة راتبك ، ولكن أيضًا
عندما نتحدث ، أعني إذا كنت
تفكر ، فلنفترض أنك تتحدث عن
ua وتريد دمج الاثنين ،
كم عدد شركات الطيران حول العالم الموجودة
في بلد واحد ،
فأنا أفهم وجهة نظرك  انظر ، دعنا ننظر إذا
كنت تريد إعطاء مثال
، فلنتحدث عن المملكة المتحدة ، فلنتحدث عن
أستراليا نتحدث عن الصين ، هل
تعتقد أنه دعونا نتخلص من
جميع شركات الطيران كشركة واحدة ثم
ما نتحدث
عنه  المنافسة في
المنافسة أمر صحي ، إنه أمر جيد ،
ولكن فيما يتعلق بالأمثلة التي قدمتها ، فإن
عدد السكان المحليين يبلغ
عشرات الملايين ، وبالتالي تبرر
نفقات شركتي نقل وانتشار جغرافي
أكبر من 100 ميل ،
فلن يكون ذلك منطقيًا أكثر وأعتقد
لماذا  أنا أسأل هذا سيدي ، هل هو
ما بعد الوباء ، مهما كان ما
قد يعتقده المرء
قبل انتشار الوباء ، فهذا ليس منطقيًا ، نعم ،
هذا صحيح ، لكننا لا
نقف في مكان واحد حيث
ينمو السكان الأعمال التجارية  زراعة
المنطقة الهوائية المحيطة وما يمكننا القيام به
مع الآخر وهذا هو السبب في أننا نثبت
أنني أعني حتى أثناء الوباء انظر
ماذا حققنا
إذا كنا نتحدث عن الإمارات
قمنا بنقل اللقاح نقلنا البضائع
الذهبية القابلة للضغط سمها
الأشخاص الذين
تعرفهم  وقد تم ذلك
لأن لدينا شركة طيران تتمتع
بمرونة قوية يمكنها القيام بعملها
وما زلنا نثبت
للعالم الذي تعلم أنه يمكننا القيام بذلك ،
لقد فعلنا ذلك من قبل
وسنفعله بعد الباندا كثيرًا  من الناس
قد خسروا
في الماضي
يراهنون ضد دبي
، نعم وسيستمرون دائمًا في الخسارة
ضد دبي ، كما تعتقد ، نعم ، دبي
هي المكان ، دبي هي العلامة التجارية ،
ما هي العلامة التجارية ، العلامة التجارية هي ما
تراه هنا عندما تأتي إلى دبي ابحث  كم
عدد الأشخاص الذين تدفقوا
على دبي
أثناء الوباء ،
أنت تعرف السبب لأننا أبقينا البلاد
مفتوحة
بالقواعد واللوائح وأيضًا
يجب أن أقول إن المساعدة تأتي
من الأشخاص
الذين يعيشون هنا والذين يتبعون
القواعد حقًا  وماذا عندما نأتي بأي
دور فهذا يعني أنه مفيد لأنفسنا
ولهم ولحمايتهم وهل تزدهر هذه
العلامة التجارية
بعد الوباء
هل تحتاج إلى تغيير كما تعلمون
دائمًا أننا في عالم يتعين علينا
تغييره طوال الوقت أيضًا
وهو شيء  سيكون أفضل للغد